dude we have our bet remember this
weekend in Israel out of Sonya and I
think Rogan is covering your nut to be
more on
I think rolling [ __ ] roadies coming
your bad puss is it - is it better live
grant is it five yeah no I would never
bet you five grapes then you're not
gonna pay no I think we'd better find
one I wanted more ridiculous cause
you're not gonna pay five to grant I
would pay I know you were the first
thing you'd say oh can I do a layaway do
we say two grand can't do a layaway I
think we said two grand you said you got
this morning I said too bad on the show
I think you said I'll bet you $5,000 and
then you went no not five more I - I
think grown went I'll cover your -
mm-hmm so here's where it gets tricky
Bryan when saw better wins who do I
collect my money from because it fits
late what that video that honey hole
video yeah no you what are you gonna do
come collect no you can't just do that
to me I wanted to come in in Crocs today
don't do it man
I have a right to pitch in the honey
hole no I have a right to do it and I'm
gonna do it I think see what happens
they do it dude I'm gonna take those
things I'm gonna pin you down with pin
you down all right you try I'm gonna pin
you down I try to slap that honey hole
around a little bit don't slap my honey
hole around because that's where I
really drop them I'm gonna slap your
honey hole down a little bit I'm gonna
take those Crocs and there's a dumpster
out front
i'ma throw them in there don't you dare
tell you don't worry I'm dude listen
here right now you've been warned the
problem is you're warning me and it's a
free country and I'm a man and I'll do
what the [ __ ] I want so I'll tell you
what there's a very good chance I'm
gonna walk through that door with Crocs
and if you want to come at me know this
brother know this brother don't call me
brother listen up bro
listen brother know this I say this as a
man it's in your in your face I say this
program don't don't [ __ ] touch my
don't touch my hand like that again dude
you rear cross if you come at me his
fist yeah in your honey hole if you come
at me just like that I say this to you
and I say this to you with it with a
full heart and clear eyes I meet you
halfway
all right you got me halfway and you
beat you and I might even meet you
before you get
why dude when style better beats Romero
I want cash I'm gonna punch in your
[ __ ] honey hole do well I'm sitting on
my oh yeah there what my honey hole
won't be there my footwork stupid now
doesn't matter what do you mean doesn't
matter what it doesn't do to have my
[ __ ] cash I will have your cash you
have my cash because uol is pissed and
your well is tired of not winning
championships you see the way do you see
him break dancing no let me see that
Yoel knows that he has one shot at this
style bender is awesome and he is the
future of the sport and I love him to
stop ever has more experience right in
kickboxing nope MMA - is more fight
that's not true not in the AFC bubble
I'm saying MMA overall record is not I
don't believe that's true but it might
be please check on that for me chin ok
wait which one either way MMA fights
folded style manner as Sabah nur is a is
a tall
[Applause]
you know your girls Zhang's fighting to
you Lana I think these two bad
[ __ ] gonna be good that's for
today started dancing so I have here
Brian
good girl said hoodie sit down
never saw better ask for this fight
you'd have to grant yo Romero title shot
he asked for it because he wanted to
prove that he can take out the best
wrestler but stop it what bloody great
stop better used to be in a dance group
so he said I used to be one I say yeah
him and his boys that's why when eat
your air when he came out against
Whitaker who knew his boys were dancing
that was his old group
backflip come on let me see that again
[ __ ] this you don't think he's gonna win
now bro no no when you can do a backflip
now hold on I need to be shitty coz fans
like god dammit Brendan it's happened a
month ago so did have a month to go
honey hold on hon I like the way he's
moving
Oh what the [ __ ] even though he's behind
him in jeans fine you gotta love that
[ __ ] hug both thumbs 40 well you
know might be 80 he is a just a freak
didn't he say I'm Rogan he goes look
walk down the street of Gilbert there
everybody looks like media what a freak
I'm excited for that fight Wow
your style Bennett is you're right he is
a giant cat he's taller me taller than
you hold me look at the food truck diary
dollar me man I was like you shocking
[ __ ] dude yeah he's so talented
well I I haven't seen him really get hit
well now that's not true Calvin Calvin
hit him know that now be down Lodi
Kelvin I hit him he played that game
because you don't want to make your wars
okay let's do help I'll meet you here is
that right prove a point yeah oh did she
Whitaker hit him at all no I did not
help I did not almost billion views I
think and I think I can validate with
numbers you the biggest star the UFC has
right now so was he well he's tall of me
if we go back to back he's gone oh I saw
it I saw the picture he's a big kid
what's your way there do you have any
idea
how'd you ask him that yeah he's broad
he's thinned fan he probably weighs 200
pounds right there
more than that I think he said was like
to Ted or something because he was like
there we talked about heavy weight you
think I could easily do it man
yeah and you too dude yeah one of my
faves he's talking you right there about
yeah I'm telling you look at that look
at them look at the bricks look at the
bricks huh yep Wow
you got a helmet of hair there don't you
we're in Spain are you from I can never
get from the word Spain you fries you're
not American I know do your Spanish as
it gets - what if I could translate
dress that might some of my here on
yours
I would I would like that I'd let you
honey homie for that right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]